Jim.
Jim
There we go.
So surly.
- Yeah!
- He needs a whiskey.
[Upbeat Music]
So, I just got off an email
thread with Caitlin and Ella
in L.A. from Buzzfeed.
They suggested that I
do a video with Rachelle
where I take her to a really
romantic spot in Paris,
show her the time of her life.
I've just been traveling
around Europe for work
for a few weeks, and I
haven't really spent much time
with Rachelle.
We should have a few days
where it's just the two of us
and do something super romantic.
But then, because I'm just
like born a cheeky bastard,
I can't help but want to mess with this.
And do something that's
genuinely going to surprise her.
And her dad is over in Scotland right now.
They haven't seen each other for awhile.
Rachelle loves all things whiskey.
She's an absolute expert.
Her brain is like a catalog
of every whiskey imaginable.
Maybe we should go to the isle of Arran,
because we've always said we've wanted to.
It's finally sunny in
Scotland, which is rare.
So, let's take advantage
of the weather right now.
It's affordable. We're living
in London at the moment,
so it's super cheap and super close.
Plus, we get to hangout with her family.
I think that this is something
that she's gonna really
remember and, hopefully, value.
Rachelle's putting makeup on right now,
thinking that we're going to Paris.
Although I'm lying right now,
it's lying with a good cause.
I'm so nervous, because I never lie.
Hey, Rachelle?
- [Rachelle] Yeah.
- You excited about our trip?
- [Rachelle] Yeah!
- Yeah! Me too.
- [Rachelle] So stoked to eat some cheese.
[Tania] How long has it been
since you've gone to Paris?
- I think about a year.
- [Tania] What are you most excited about?
- Eating. You sit on the side
of the road, you look out,
people watch.
- Finally, we have some
quality time together.
- Yeah!
- In the most romantic city in the world.
Say bye to the house.
- Bye, house. See you soon.
- There's a vibrator on the floor.
- Yeah.
- [Tania] It's pretty
early isn't it, baby?
- So early in the morning.
[Upbeat Music]
Here we're walking to check
in. She still doesn't know.
Rachelle?
- Yes?
- If you weren't going to
Paris, would you be upset?
Come here for a sec.
We're still going somewhere.
- Okay. Where are we going?
- Well, you know how I was working,
and we weren't hanging out for awhile.
We have a few days off.
- Yes.
- And we really wanted
to take advantage of it
and do something romantic.
- And go to Paris.
- Yeah, but I thought that's very generic.
So, instead, I lied, and I
got us tickets to Scotland.
I thought maybe we could see your dad.
And go to some whiskey distilleries.
And just do something that,
like, you actually really love
and enjoy.
- Yeah!
So, we're not going to Paris?
- No.
- Are you mad?
- No! No, I'm excited. I just didn't know!
- I think this is more...
you.
But maybe I'm wrong.
- No, it is. It is.
It's exciting.
We'll get to see Scotland.
- Yeah, and your family home.
- And the fam.
- I brought my turtleneck.
Because I was trying to be French.
- Baby, you can be French in Scotland.
I'm sorry for lying.
- It's okay.
- There's no more lying.
- Are you sure?
- Yeah!
[Tania] How are you feeling?
- Good!
- Have the most romantic
holiday of your life.
No pressure.
- In Scotland.
- I mean, the pressure's on me really.
Have you missed vlogging?
Isn't that part of the romance to capture
every single intimate moment
and share it with the entire world?
[Upbeat Music]
[Tania] That's Arran.
Hopefully we can get
tickets to Arran tomorrow.
It's a beautiful day in Scotland.
And they're not quite used
to this amount of sun.
We saw online that most
of the ferry tickets
have already been booked out.
So, it's going to be a bit shit
if we don't manage to get
tickets to go to Arran.
But I guess this is the
downside of not planning things
and going to small country towns.
Normally I'm, like, super organized.
I overproduce everything in my life.
Rachelle's always the
one that's teaching me
to take it as it comes.
If it doesn't work, it doesn't work.
Her dad's going to come.
So, it's not just going
to be the two of us,
but we knew that going into it.
Well, I knew that going into this.
I'm kind of just at a
point in my life where
these things mean a lot to me.
I've heard that there's a castle there
and some beautiful walks along the path.
And everything is just a bus ride away.
So, it should be easy getting around.
I feel like I'm getting sicker, though.
Hopefully it doesn't get any worse.
[Wistful Music]
Just woke up a little while
ago. She sounds healthy, too.
Can't wait for an hour boat ride.
I was actually sick a couple days ago,
and I've been trying to fight it.
I wasn't even going to mention it,
but it's come back with a vengeance.
I'm sure I'll be fine.
So, Rachelle, you've never been to Arran.
- [Rachelle] I've never been to Arran.
- I've never been.
But it's been 40 years for you, Jim.
- [Jim] Yes.
- Wow.
So, you've virtually never been either.
- [Jim] That's right.
- [Tania] What an adventure.
We've got tickets!
It's huge!
It looks like we're walking
into another quarantine.
[Cheerful Music]
It's a beautiful day.
It's really nice to be
hanging out with family!
[Pleasant Fiddle Music]
- [Rachelle] Do you like it, Dad?
- Aye!
- Shots! Shots! Shots!
Shots! Shots! Shots!
It sucks that I feel so sick.
I feel like just the smell
of the barley and malt
just kind of hit my nose.
And I don't know if you've
been in a distillery before,
but imagine being in a perfumery.
That is what it kind of smelled like.
But now we're out in the fresh air.
This is Rachelle's dad's
first whiskey tour.
And now we're just going to
explore the island a little bit,
see what we can find.
- How you feeling, Tania?
- [Tania] It was so informative.
I didn't know that the
shape of the still affected
the chemical reduction
and, therefore, the taste of whiskeys.
What did you think of it, whiskey expert?
- [Rachelle] I thought it was
good. It's a nice distillery.
Nice and modern.
- Are you going to share your cake, or no?
- [Tania] That's all your dad cares about.
- [Rachelle] But can I do it!
- [Tania] We're about to
walk through a castle.
[Peppy Pop Music]
It's our last morning in Scotland.
- Have you had a good time?
- Yes. It's just been relaxing,
which is exactly what we need.
- It was so good.
- It was a bit ad hoc.
- Yeah!
But what we did see was
absolutely beautiful.
- [Tania] Despite the nausea.
That just added some drama.
It was nice for me to
hangout with your dad.
What do you think you prefer
more in terms of dates?
- [Rachelle] Oh, yeah.
- [Tania] Kind of just
spontaneous, not well-planned?
- [Rachelle] I prefer the outdoor stuff.
I prefer walking around on an
island, taking the boat out,
than hanging out in a city.
It's nice, and that's not to say Paris
isn't a romantic place.
But I think you can find it
in different corners of the earth.
- [Tania] Even though we were
with family the whole time?
- Yeah!
- Last summer, me and my
friends wanted to surprise
our other friend for his birthday.
So, we came up with this
whole elaborate plan
that one of our friends lost
her purity ring at the beach.
So, she and him went off to
the beach to look for it,
while we stayed at the
house and decorated.
When he came back, we all
screamed, "Happy birthday!"
And it was so much fun.
- I surprised my boyfriend
with an ultimate date.
I took him to a PNC Pirates game,
and afterwards we went
to a trivia wine night.
And I kept it a secret the entire night.
He only knew where we were
going once we got there.
- I surprised one of my friends
with a surprise birthday party.
I invited all of our friends.
And we sat in my backyard.
We had drinks. We swam in my pool.
She still tells me that's
one of her favorite
birthday memories, so it
makes it that much better.
- Hey! Unsolved is on a new
channel. And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here!
- That was my part.